hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
I'm a property investor and on this Q&A
Sunday I'm gonna be giving a lot of very
interesting unique perspectives on
property investing you see Ibn loads of
questions from the last week's video I'm
going to be answering and addressing all
the questions but I've been getting in
the comment box on YouTube what I want
you to do as a viewer someone watching
this video right now is I want you to
listen take notes enjoy but also comment
your questions below and next Sunday I'm
going to answer your property investment
questions so anything about how to get
into property how to finance of property
how to be a property entrepreneur
anything at all nicholae small big broad
specific comment below let's see what
questions we had last week Melanie
Melanie says Sammy will love your
content but I think the background noise
is a bit distracting my bad
hopefully on this video the background
noise is less distracting but just my
personal opinion would you go for off
market plan properties they offer seven
percent reassured when in the first year
and deals seem to be quite good all
rather go for older properties which are
slightly cheaper but might require some
maintenance Melanie thank you for your
amazing question and I hope the music is
more suited to your tastes this week
listen I'd be really careful about
properties like that because when they
give you a guaranteed rent like that
with a deal for the first year I've had
this happen before I've bought packaged
investments and what sometimes happens
is it's guaranteed they do give it you
for the first year but what they do is
they give you more the first year than
you're ever gonna get ever again and
they use that as a sales tool to get you
to buy the property because you think oh
wow guaranteed rent for the first year
of I grand a month but then after the
year it drops to 400 pan a month and
you're this is terrible investment
because you just assumed guaranteed for
the first year will probably maintain
the same you know so I'd be really
careful on that friend also did you say
it was a new build new builds if you buy
a property there's a new build as an
investment often what happens is you buy
it and the value drops trailer I Melanie
would be very careful I would find your
own deals and I would find ya probably
older properties and be very very
careful and if you want to send more
details on what you're being offered I'm
happy to look at it but be careful
that's my advice
what else we got Erastus corn oh man
arrest as he says thanks for the useful
nuggets of info SL welcome thank you for
watching and being a subscriber you
better be subscribed or I'll find you I
want to buy a four-bed and convert it to
a 6 bed HMO I am worried about licenses
should I go with a builder and a council
officer for a viewing before purchase
and then do a Rick's valuation before I
make a firm offer and can the council
deny me a license after doing all the
works on the initial visit using
bridging for the first time so very
cautious about it thanks Erastus I want
to say two things firstly I want to say
it's right that you should be cautious
getting a bridging loan on buying a
cello when you don't fully understand
the licensing and all the rules and
stuff that is something that is quite a
big deal for a first-time investor I
don't know if your first time or not but
that's a big deal so that's the first
thing you're right to be cautious second
thing I'll say is you're right to be
taking action and to be doing this and
to be watching the videos and going out
looking at properties so you know you've
not certainly thinking this which makes
me think that you're missing the big
picture or you're ignorant of something
what I would say though is you say
you're worried about getting that you're
worried about the licenses and you find
out very easily if a property is going
to need a license or not and you can do
that on Google and generally speaking if
it's a hey Chel which is gonna hold five
or more people you'll need a license
getting a license isn't that bad and
your right to speak to the council to
see what the crack is before you buy the
house also to get a building before you
buy the house that's correct
you're also it's never a bad idea to get
a Ric's valuation depending on what the
plan is with the property you probably
don't need to get a Ric's valuation just
to buy it you can just if you're getting
a mortgage on the property which you
should be because you should be using a
loan to buy the property you mentioned
the bridging a bridging loan so are you
talking Ric's valuation on the end value
in which case smart if you're just
buying it as a buy-to-let / HMO buying
it and renting out you I wouldn't I
wouldn't get a Ric's valuation
necessarily because if you're getting
financed on the property the lender is
going to need to go around the property
and they'll give you an idea of the
value of the house so that's just some
general thoughts
to me like you probably could do some
extra training I'd recommend you go
check out Samuel 365 if you go on Samuel
365.com you'll be able to join a
community where you can ask questions
talk have access to myself and that
coaches and we're about to walk you
through this deal good job good luck
keep us posted okay BMX vloggers cool
man good to have you with us do you did
you know anything about property when
you bought your first house at 17 yes I
did know stuff about property when I
bought my first house at 17 I didn't
know as much as I know now nowhere near
but I knew more than most people and
even though I was only 17 not educated I
educated myself so when I left school at
16 and I became a property investor why
he decided I wanted to be a property
investor or I went on some training
programs and I really learn my craft and
it's I think people underestimate how
fast you can get knowledge when you go
on training programs don't network and
put yourself out there you can get up to
speed pretty quick it's a lot my
property investors crash course it's a
two-day crash course you're online now
but it's a two-day program you can get
very good knowledge in a couple days
so although 17 was very young I don't
have any experience I knew quite a bit
about property because I'd learned
because I trained myself did I make
mistakes
absolutely you know but I knew a
reasonable amount bought my first house
in 17 and I put it in someone else's
name a family member's name actually my
stepdad and he kind of was my like a
guarantor held it for me until I was old
enough and able to then switch over to
my name that's how my first deal worked
great question though I don't know how
old you are but get smart get educated
and go crazy okay
um had shrah ha-- drat
good to have you with us hey drew hi
Samuel please speak about how rules
regarding HMOs in Oxford differ from
other areas I'm interested in read to
rent in Oxford very specific question
there in Oxford I do know about Oxford
and HMOs I've got I haven't got any HMOs
personally Oxford I do have a serviced
accommodation unit which I use as a
holiday like a holiday home type thing
my some of my students have HMOs in
Oxford they have rent - hmm as well so
how it works
HMOs in Oxford is you need a license
check this out on the HMO web
on the council website oxford but i'm
very confident this is correct
so HMO will need a license even if
there's only three people in the house
normally for a HMO there's got to be
five or more people for you to need a
HMO license whereas in oxford three
people or more you need a license that's
my understanding
getting a license she's not that
difficult it might cost around about
eight hundred pounds that will last five
years so that's the rules in Oxford
about licensing which I think was your
question so check it out on Google you
can find all this information out on
Google though just like type it in a
chomo rules in Oxford and it'll all come
up so good luck go smash it HMO rent to
rents very very good strategy in Oxford
so good luck to that good luck with that
all right Craig
eka man he says hi Samuel thank you for
another great video you're welcome by
the way if you're enjoying this video
don't forget to smash the like button
also I want your questions your
questions is what gives me content so
comment like crazy below anything at all
comment below and I'm gonna do my very
best to answer your questions next week
even if it's like an offshoot of one of
these questions or you don't quite
understand ask your question be specific
hello go so Craig says thank you for a
great video I have a question for you I
am completing on my fourth investment
property this week respect
congratulations
and I mainly focus on purchase from a
below market value where I be ar-ar-ar
which means buy refurbish refinance rent
good for you Craig good job managed to
negotiate a further six thousand pounds
off of the house I'm about to complete
on due to Corona well done so the
figures all work out very well my
question is do you think that at some
point even though BRR our model on a
single let properties is fairly low risk
if you have the knowledge do you think
at some point you have to make the
decision to go on to bigger and better
things or do you think that if you're
having success let's stick to what you
know best thanks in advance Craig that's
a really really good question and you're
very you're clearly very successful
you're very smart and you're doing
really well you've got three properties
already that have worked really well
you've now got your fourth property so
your question is if it's not broken why
fix it right you're doing it you're
putting your money in you pushing the
value up by refurb in it you're
refinancing putting your money out and
you're recycling again and again and
it's working
what I agree with that to a point here's
what's gonna happen if you keep doing
that over and over and over again and to
be honest this is kind of like what I
did so I understand you're gonna end up
with like a massive property portfolio
maybe 20 30 houses all these single
debts giving you three four hundred quid
a month you'll be financially free
you'll be reasonably wealthy but now
you've got a whole bunch of properties a
whole bunch of tenants and personally I
don't think the winner in property is
the person who has the most properties I
think the winner is the person making
the most money and sometimes we get
really hung up I'm wanting to get lots
and lots of properties what I ended up
doing over the last couple of years I've
been selling off all of my small deals
I've been putting them into bigger deals
you will make much more money Craig on
bigger deals and the same amount of
effort on a small deal is required on a
big deal
so if I were you what I would do Craig
is I would start going bigger and bigger
and scaling up now the reason I tell
most people to start with small deals is
because you usually mess up on your
first deal when you just starting out
you messed up starting out you want to
mess up on the small deals you want to
mess up on these 50 grand hundred grand
houses you don't want to mess it up on
buying a piece of land and building
eight houses you don't want to mess up
on turning a massive pub into twelve
apartments because you mess up on man it
could bankrupt you so you want to build
to that but once you've got the
experience if you know how to buy I buy
a 80 grand house spend 20 grand on it
then reevaluate at 125 and pull your
money out if you know how to do that
you've done that three four times I
wouldn't keep doing it over and over I
would I would I would move to something
that's gonna stretch you I would move to
a bigger deal maybe say right I've done
a few single that's and it's kind of
working
great but what's the long-term goal your
long-term goal is to get 20 of those and
then retired then maybe but my goal
always is a property investor and as an
entrepreneur and as a person is to be
the biggest version of myself I can be
to make as much money as much impact to
then help as many people like that's how
I think big think growing stretching so
if you're anything like me what I would
do is I'd slowly go into bigger bigger
bigger bigger bigger deals so that in
two three years you're working on big
stuff because that
it's just as easy well I bought a castle
and that's been renovated that's given
me less headaches and some of my like
three hundred thousand pound deals or
even like my hundred grand deals which
is just bizarre because there's so much
more money you can you can afford to pay
people to manage it and do it for you
just as much effort on a big in a small
deal so that's my advice Greg respect
keep me posted how you getting on I hope
to see you on Samuel 3-6-5 get down to
join the community RB five to eight six
four really like well okay fine that
sounds like a very strange account um
you pay yourself one hundred thousand
pounds yeah pretty much of payments left
ten grand a month
one twenty but keep the properties in
your own name not exactly but anyway
that would be a loss making exercise you
also said you buy properties via a
limited company which one is it okay um
both I used to buy in my own name now I
buy in a company I now by Anna company
because they changed the rules
they changed the tax rules it's now more
tax efficient to buying a company now I
buying a company but in the past I used
to buy in my own name so I don't quite
understand the question exactly I'm kind
of a little bit confused but I hope that
clears it up and also the properties
that I built up over the first like
eight years of being a property investor
which I bought in my own name for me too
people often ask me this is a second
I've got properties in my own name it's
no longer tax efficient how can I
transfer them into a company and the
answer is you can but it's very
expensive for me to transfer to my
properties from my personal name into a
company I've looked at it I'd like to
pay stamp duty on every property that I
transfer so it's a very that's a very
expensive exercise the money that I'd
have the money that it would cost me in
stamp duty in accountancy fees and the
rest of it to transfer my individual
properties into a company would be so
expensive then it wouldn't be worth the
money that I'd saved in tax it doesn't
really make any sense also the
properties that I own in an individual
name are making pretty good cash flow so
while section 24 and the new tax
Changez have hit me I'm not gonna lie
they've hit me but my mortgage payments
are quite small like two three hundred
pounds a month my rent is highlight a
lot of my houses HMOs I'm making like
twelve thirteen fifteen two grand a
month so the mortgage payments small so
section 24 not hit me as bad as its hit
a lot of amateur landlords that have got
that I've got high mortgage and the rent
just covers it just washes its face so
I'm kind of okay but now I'm buying in a
company and I own quite a lot of houses
in the company most of them are
unencumbered most of them haven't got
mortgages on them and and and and and
that's I'm changing them refinancing I'm
selling I'm going into bigger deals so
there are 100 percent understand your
question I'm always very open about me
and my business so yeah let me mister
rb5 28064 hope that helped you in your
journey I somehow don't think that it
did though I somehow don't think that
you finding out my business helps your
business but maybe it does somehow I'm
not sure anyway good luck what's next oh
wow [ __ ] how ok cool I don't know if
that's your real name or your user name
but let's see what you got hi Samuel
hope you doing well I'm doing really
well thank so much Ruskin as a deal
sorcerer you're pretty much selling the
information about a property so can you
sell and package any property info
around the world for example package of
Swedish property yes and no firstly I
wouldn't say that you're just selling
the information if you're a deal if
you're a deal sorcerer you're not you
can't charge three four five grand just
for information in terms of like here's
a property these are the details good
luck you can't really do that so you're
what you're selling is you're selling
you're selling a package deal you found
a property you've done your due
diligence on it you've negotiated the
price you've spoke to the seller you've
got an agent in the area it's gonna be
able to manage it you've got it ready
and now you sell it so can you do that
from overseas yes you can you can do
that over the phone you can negotiate
you can do everything yes overseas
probably better to get someone to view
it but that doesn't need to be you so
you can do it from overseas you can
package deals from all over the country
all over the world and you can sell them
for my laptop from home you can but
don't get it twisted you
not just selling information and the
reason I say that is because there are
some deal sources that just find leads
and sell them for extortion of fees if
you want to sell leads that's a whole
nother thing if you want to just say hey
I've got a little bit of an opportunity
I've got this lead that's come in but
you can only sell a lead for like a
couple hundred quid maybe even less
selling a deal is a different thing and
selling a deal you someone is to have
seen it
use your properly packaged it and put it
together that's a wrap I hope you guys
enjoyed it I hope you did a lot I look
forward to reading your comments below
drop em drop them drop them listen guys
if you enjoyed this channel please
subscribe like honestly
and also smash the like button it helps
the algorithm I love serving you I love
answering your questions I can't wait to
see you on the next video don't ask them
a question and then don't subscribe
because if you ask a question and then I
answer it next week
you are even know I answer that you
won't know I called you out so you've
got to subscribe we've got to turn on
the notification a bow and I look
forward to answering more questions next
Sunday at 7 p.m.
god bless see you tomorrow
[Music]